[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden asegura que occidente no tuvo nada
que ver con la rebelión del grupo Wagner
contra la cúpula militar de Rusia otros
líderes mundiales también se
pronunciaron tras lo ocurrido china
expresó su apoyo al kremlin ante la
crisis
cadena perpetua para el hombre que
asesinó a cinco personas en un bar lgbt
de Colorado en noviembre pasado el
atacante de 23 años se declaró culpable
de asesinato aunque no reconoció el odio
como motivo del crimen
Guatemala va a elegir entre el acento
derechista Sandra Torres o el
socialdemócrata Bernardo Arévalo en la
segunda vuelta presidencial del 20 de
agosto mientras la Torre se abarca la
élite política tradicional Arévalo se
postula como la opción para reconstruir
las instituciones democráticas
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
mas deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarlos
empezamos en Estados Unidos por qué tras
guardar horas de silencio el presidente
Joe biden entre otros mandatarios
rechazó públicamente las acusaciones de
que occidente estuvo detrás de la
rebelión del grupo Wagner contra la
cúpula militar rusa hagamos a
continuación un repaso por las
reacciones internacionales a la crisis
el capítulo de La rebelión del grupo
Wagner sigue provocando reacciones en
todo el mundo el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden aseguró que ni su país
ni sus aliados estaban detrás del motín
de Wagner como bien sinuano Rusia
estuvieron de acuerdo conmigo en que
teníamos que asegurarnos de no darle
excusas a Putin Permítame enfatizar no
le dimos excusas a Putin para culpar a
occidente o culpar a la otan dejamos
Claro que no estábamos involucrados no
tenemos nada que ver con eso Esto fue
parte de una lucha dentro del sistema
ruso
el Primer Ministro canadiense Yo sin
crudo y su eco de las afirmaciones de
biden aseguró que las potencias
occidentales están evaluando la
situación de cerca estamos observando
por supuesto y estamos reflexionando
cuidadosamente sobre Cuáles podrían ser
las implicaciones ya sea en Ucrania o en
cualquier otro lugar a lo largo de
Europa del este Reino Unido calificó los
sucesos del fin de semana como algo sin
precedentes y argumentó que ilustraron
la ilegitimidad de la invasión rusa
Ucrania ha dejado Claro que esta guerra
de agresión fue impulsada por los egos
del presidente Putin y el círculo
inmediato que lo rodea china por su
parte reiteró su apoyo a Rusia e informó
que han dialogado con las altas esferas
del kremlin
como vecino amistoso de Rusia es socio
cooperativo estratégico integral para la
Nueva Era china apoya y cree en las
capacidades de Rusia para mantener la
estabilidad nacional y lograr el
desarrollo y la prosperidad China y
Rusia mantienen una estrecha y buena
comunicación en todos los niveles la
atención
asegurara que Rusia había abierto una
investigación sobre si los servicios de
inteligencia de occidente estuvieron
Implicados En la rebelión
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque la
justicia de Colorado condenó a cadena
perpetua al hombre de 23 años que mató a
cinco personas en un tiroteo en un bar
lgbt en noviembre pasado el atacante
evitó un largo proceso judicial al
declararse culpable de los delitos de
asesinato
las familias de las víctimas aliviadas
por la justicia fueron cinco las
personas a las que Anderson lealdrich
les arrebató la vida el 19 de noviembre
de 2022 dejó también decenas de heridos
tras abrir fuego en el club un bar
nocturno lgbtiq más en Colorado Springs
ante el juez reconoció la autoría
mientras analizo los documentos veo que
tiene la intención de declararse
culpable de cinco cargos de asesinato en
el primer grado
46 cargos de intento de asesinato en
primer grado y dos delitos motivados por
prejuicios
es esto lo que desea hacer
si su señoría
aldrich evitó lo que pudo haber sido un
juicio largo el atacante de 23 años fue
condenado a cinco cadenas perpetuas por
los delitos de asesinato e intento de
asesinato sin embargo los sobrevivientes
a la masacre esperaban que el atacante
también declarara por los cargos de odio
y delitos motivados por prejuicios pero
no sucedió el daño en la sociedad está
hecho Dijo uno de los sobrevivientes
no hay una resolución que sea positiva
porque a todos Todavía nos falta mucho
un compañero un hijo una hija un mejor
amigo alguien se ha ido eso nunca podrá
ser devuelto a través del sistema de
Justicia Colorado ya no tiene un
estatuto de pena de muerte pero si los
fiscales lo consideran necesario el
atacante también podría enfrentar la
sentencia capital en un tribunal Federal
la ONU advirtió que los derechos humanos
de la comunidad de sexo y género diverso
están siendo socavados deliberadamente
por leyes discriminatorias en algunos
estados de la Unión Americana antes de
Colorado la comunidad lgbtiq más había
sido blanco de otro mortífero ataque con
el tiroteo de la discoteca pauls en
Orlando que en 2016 dejó 49 muertos
cambiamos de tema pasamos al Salvador
porque nayib bukele se inscribió como
candidato presidencial para las
elecciones de 2024 esto a pesar de que
la Constitución prohíbe la reelección
inmediata de un mandatario sin embargo
la interpretación legal podría cambiar
porque en 2021 jueces afines a bukele de
la sala constitucional de la Corte
Suprema emitieron una resolución que
podría permitir la reelección
seguimos en Centroamérica vamos a
Guatemala porque tras la primera vuelta
de las elecciones generales de ayer
quedaron definidos los dos candidatos
para el balotaje por un lado la centro
derecha Sandra Torres que partía como
favorita y por otro el socialdemócrata
Bernardo Arévalo que fue la sorpresa de
la jornada previamente la politóloga
María los Chan nos analizó el panorama
hay que también identificar Quién es el
vicepresidenciable de Sandra Torres es
un ex pastor de la comunidad evangélica
iglesia evangélica Y eso le ha venido
muy bien a Sandra Torres para poder
posicionarse dentro del Gran grupo de
conservadores que existen en Guatemala
sobre esos temas que le preocupan a esa
población verdad estamos hablando de
temas de aborto estamos hablando de la
concepción de la familia tradicional
pero en temas específicos de política
pública de Cómo resolver el tema del
alto costo de la vida como resolver el
tema de la inseguridad Yo te diría que
no hay una gran diferencia entre ambos
políticos verdad Sandra Torres continúa
ofreciendo y duplicando la política de
programas sociales para poder asegurarle
a la gente mejores condiciones sociales
pero no hace una gran propuesta o una
gran reforma a políticas públicas que
efectivamente sí saquen a las personas
de la pobreza y no sean subsidiarios
nada más es histórico lo que logró
Bernardo Arévalo porque por mucho tiempo
los analistas y me incluyo asumimos que
la única forma para poder asegurarse una
victoria en las elecciones generales de
Guatemala o por lo menos pasará a
segunda vuelta requeríamos de tres cosas
uno campañas millonarias dos tener una
exposición alta dentro de los canales de
televisión abierta verdad que son los
canales que llegan a todos los hogares
de los guatemaltecos y tres el
beneplácito o el o el agrado de las
élites económicas del país temía no
tiene ninguna de esas tres Y de alguna u
otra forma logró colarse a la segunda
vuelta en otras noticias Naciones Unidas
acusa a Estados Unidos de flagrantes
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos en
la prisión de guantánamo la relatora de
la ONU por la protección de los Derechos
Humanos en la lucha antiterrorista
señaló las deficiencias estructurales en
la atención médica o directamente en el
acceso a la justicia de los prisioneros
de hecho la relatora expuso que cada uno
de los detenidos con los que habló sufre
los traumas causados por la tortura y la
detención arbitraria
este informe defiende los derechos de
las víctimas del terrorismo a la
justicia a la rendición de cuentas y a
la transparencia pero encuentro que la
Barrera más significativa para el
cumplimiento de los derechos de las
víctimas y sobrevivientes fue el uso de
la tortura la tortura fue una traición a
los derechos de las víctimas de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre el
gobierno de Estados Unidos debe brindar
urgentemente resolución judicial
disculpas y garantías de no repetición
y cerramos en Colombia porque ahí el
presidente Gustavo Petro condecoró a 86
personas la felicitación oficial fue
para los militares y los indígenas que
participaron en la operación Esperanza
para encontrar a los cuatro menores que
se perdieron en la selva después de un
accidente de avioneta Petro dijo que la
unión inédita entre la fuerza pública y
los grupos originarios debe extenderse a
toda la nación para preservar la vida
sin embargo ya desistieron de seguir
buscando al perro de rescate Wilson
quien se perdió en el operativo
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
pero sigan con más información en 24 y
24 punto com
[Música]